What do you want to know I'll tell you given you
What would you get this time around of directing is there anything different or didn't you learned or what's your approach?
would
uh it was it was a bit of a
challenge
an increased challenge
because I was
While we're coming off hiatus so it's like the first thing getting back into it [now]. I'm directing
But I'm also having to introduce essentially a new character
Which is you know?
Demonic version of Dean
[and] it's I find it difficult. I was saying another table over there. I'm like
I don't know how you know ben affleck or ben stiller
or
You know [even] going back like mel gibson with braveheart or dances with wolves and come across terms like I'd love to ask them like
How do you guys do it because I find it very difficult to
take the directors hat off and put the actors hat on and then vice versa, so
And then also trying to introduce a new character at the same time it was it was a head spin
Hopefully hopefully it worked out awfully you guys like it, but you know, we'll see I actually go into
editing on Tuesday to to cut to give them my cut so
Nervous well there's certainly a benefit to living with the character living on the skin of the character or so long as you have done
But what is the largest challenge?
Of living with a character for that long, it'll [be] having to let him go eventually [I]
Think I
Think it's a good question. He said he said living with a character for so long
What's the biggest challenge of living with that character, and I said it'll probably be letting him go yeah
Yeah, absolutely
[that's] gonna be really difficult. I want him without but I think one [of] them
I think the in my opinion the biggest challenge of living with character is solved by
Frankly by the show Supernatural because usually a character becomes stagnant or stale and boring
but we do so many crazy wild things and we're able to because the fans forgive us and they stay with [us] and
supernatural is such a show that you can do anything you can become a demon you can become an angel you can go soulless and
You get to explore all these new different facets
It's not like we're playing guys who are in high school
And now there's really there's like a now there's a romance with this person. Now is really fun. What's next like what's going to happen?
It's just crazy bizarre show. We can literally go anywhere, and we almost have
So that's the that's the most different part of currently living with [characters]. Make sure he doesn't go stale
But it also each other it'll bounce off [of] - yeah. I [mean], [it's] you know. There's it's just kind of like it
You know the equalizer. You know it's like
I've [got] I've got dean and I've got him in [my] head, and I've got all this stuff
but then as soon as they all cut
It's like he and I kind of bring each other right back out of it number
You know Jarrid again, so it's it's there's there's a nice balance that comes with having somebody that you work with so close
you know as opposed [to] you know somebody like Stephen amell or from like Tom welling who's really kind of
Solo flying solo
You know we effectively he tells Stephen all [the] [time] [is] like too bad
It's just you because you know how we had is you're having a partner in Crime is really the way to go
you